two days ago there was a really tragic
accident in a town called Boston a small
town to the east of Nottingham about 50
miles away where five people died in an
explosion it was suggested in several of
these articles that they may have been
involved in the illegal distillation of
alcohol quite a few people have asked us
wise distillation of alcohol dangerous
we've seen you doing it on the videos
and it looks quite innocuous and people
drink alcohol in brandy and vodka
sometimes they even smoke while drinking
and they don't blow themselves up we
have no idea what happened in this
incident in Boston but because of these
questions it seems quite a good
opportunity just to emphasize to people
what are the dangers of distilling
alcohol yourself and why you shouldn't
really try it unless your specialist
alcohol is an inflammable liquid in
Brazil it's used instead of gasoline in
people's cars ain't it car engines but
it only really burns fast or explodes
when it's in a vapor phase because when
it's in a liquid it doesn't burn very
quickly and in an explosion you need
some sort of vapor in this case alcohol
which is mixed with air and when you
ignite set fire to a little part of this
it starts burning and the heat from that
first ignition warms up the material
around it so that material reacts faster
and so the reaction goes faster and
faster and faster and builds up in speed
and as the heat goes the gas tries to
expand it creates an increase in
pressure and the pressure build up and
the fast reaction gives you an explosion
now in the distillation you take a
mixture of alcohol and water you've done
some sort of fermentation of starch or
some sugar and you get mixture of
alcohol and water and you heat it up and
the vapor that comes off is alcohol
vapor and usually what you do in
distillation if you're doing properly
you pass this into a cold tube so called
condenser which converts the vapor back
into a liquid and then there is very
little danger on the other hand if your
condenser is not working properly if the
water cooling it is not going through
fast enough if you forget to switch the
water on at all then the alcohol vapor
will not condense and will just come out
at the end of the apparatus you can't
see the vapor you probably can't smell
it because there are all sorts of other
smells in the room and so the room fills
up with this in
flammable vapor and as it builds up in
the room so you eventually reach the
so-called explosion limit which means if
you set it off there is enough alcohol
in the air that the explosion will
propagate and will build up in force and
if you're doing something illegally you
probably don't want other people to see
it so you will be perhaps in a
relatively small room and your apparatus
will be producing quite a lot of heat
high temperature means more vapor can
stay in the air it can be ignited more
easily and if it's a closed room you're
containing the pressure wave so again
the effects can be more disastrous so
let me emphasize we have no idea what
happened in Boston and we have great
sympathy for the relatives of the people
who died but we would like to emphasize
that even something as simple as
distillation of alcohol can be really
quite dangerous if you're doing it
particularly on a large scale and you're
not professionally involved if you do it
right professionally you have a proper
distillery you can make wonderful drinks
that produce pleasure for many people
but on the other hand if you're trying
to do it as an amateur you can have the
most disastrous results which will just
bring misery
to you and everyone else